we talked about
injured guys last hour gronk is a guy
who's been injured throughout his career
i refer to him as cavity sam from time
to time the guy from the operation game
because he's had about every procedure
you can imagine he had the horrible
arm injury that had multiple infections
and multiple surgeries had a picc line
at one point it was that bad
and he continues to just keep going and
going and yes he took 2019 off and it
apparently has helped for now shireen
he's healthy he's looking good for the
tampa bay buccaneers i think the real
question is how aggressively will they
use him especially early in the season
as they break him back in because
everyone's healthy until it's time to
start playing the games that's what
makes guys not healthy is getting out
there and being hit and dragged down to
the ground and being shoved around and
uh you know that's the concern and uh
for now though gronk uh healthier than
he's looked in years because he doesn't
have that wear and tear and he seems to
be happy in tampa bay and it sure didn't
seem like he was happy those last years
in new england
i'm the idiot last week who said he was
going to have a thousand yards this
season for the first time since 2017. so
i hope he's out there and i hope he's
playing but it has been since 2011 that
he's played a full season but maybe the
year off did do him good the last time
he played two years ago he played 75
percent of the snaps i think that's
probably somewhere along the lines of
what the bucks will look at you know we
talked about taking days off during the
week of training camp i think you're
gonna see veteran off days for him too
during the season uh he'll take probably
a thursday off or whatever it is and and
rest that body and make sure he's right
for game day but i do think the year off
is going to do him good and i think he's
going to have a big season for the bucks
yes they have a lot of tight ends there
i think they'll go with a lot of two
tight-end formations but i think grock's
going to have a big gear and i think
he's going to stay healthy this season
i mentioned last week the mental
gymnastics i went through when they
acquired gronk technically in a trade
with the patriots because he still was
under contract to them he was on their
reserve retired list
you have oj howard you have cameron
brade in comes gronkwell oj howard's
getting traded and that was my first
reaction and then i started thinking
about it's like wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
gronk was extremely effective
as a guy who was used more and more
later in the season in 2018 he didn't
have a big 2018 season with the patriots
to the point where we just kind of wrote
him off he's not the guy he used to be
then came the postseason oh and he's the
guy he used to be so i think they are
going to ease him in i think we aren't
going to see him used extensively early
in the season maybe they trade o.j
howard or cameron breit in late october
and then that's when it becomes gronk
plus whoever's left with a push toward
the postseason but that's why i think
it's not going to be the gronk show
right out of the gates from his
perspective he addressed yesterday what
his role will be what his reps will be
how much work he will get here's gronk
addressing what he will actually be
doing on the field for the tampa bay
buccaneers
i'll play the whole entire game if i
have to it's up to the coaches um with
the amount of playing time i get it's up
to the coaches with the amount of reps i
get i've just listened to my coach every
single practice whenever he puts me in
he puts me in whenever he takes me out
he takes me out i'm feeling good out
there my body feels good that's why i
came back to the game and that's how i
want to be moving i want to be moving
like how i was back in the day
no doubt about that why why else would i
want to come back to the game and be
moving like poop
[Laughter]
he's a poet
i just had a flashback
you know he's the author of a book
um
and and when he did his radio tour
five years ago i think it was now
and i gave him the chance at the end of
the interview to make the pitch
gronk tell everyone out there why they
should go buy your book and his response
was you know that's a good question i'm
not sure why they should buy the book so
uh yeah uh the the sequel coming up from
rob gronkowski based upon his year in
tampa bay but you know sharing here's
the thing
and
there were periodic points during his
career where there was an obsession with
how do you stop rob gronkowski because
you can't
who you double team him who do you
double team him with who can begin to
slow him down and the patriots never
really had
the weapon
around rob gronkowski that also had to
be double teamed the buccaneers have
a guy in mike evans who needs to be
doubled and if gronk is healthy and out
there extensively
he needs to be doubled
uh they're going to have a hell of a
time accounting
for
evans and gronk when both guys are on
the field which creates a greater
temptation if you're the coach to tell
gronk get your butt out there to create
these mismatches that the defense isn't
going to be able to deal with
and chris got one too i mean they are
loaded and you talked about the other
two tight ends yeah this is a team that
you look across the board it's gonna
heart be hard to double all the
receivers and tight ends that you need
to double as a defensive coordinator i
think it's gonna be very very difficult
against this team but back to your point
of florida versus new england what he
went through the early games in tampa
are brutal you know it's it's humid
there i covered the buccaneers i lived
there it's it's brutal with the humidity
it's going to be different for him than
it was in new england for those first
few games that they have at home and it
extends into october it's not just like
it's the first game you know it's going
to be the first two three four uh home
games that they have are going to be
really hot and really humid and maybe
they do ease him in because of that
and get him ready but as long as he's
ready late in the season when it matters
in the playoffs because i do think this
is a playoff team especially with the
expanded playoffs i think he's going to
be ready and i think he's going to make
a difference for the buck
when tom brady walks up to the line of
scrimmage after 20 years experience in
the nfl and he said after the win over
the falcons
three plus years ago in the super bowl
you can't show me anything i haven't
already seen he's going to walk up to
the line he's going to know looking at
the defense whether they are shading
toward evans shading toward gronk who's
going to be open he knows where the
guy's going to be he's going to get that
ball out so fast and if he gets it to
one of these guys who's single covered
they're evans and gronk are so big it
doesn't matter if you got one guy on him
that this has the potential to be a very
very good offense a very very good team
and however much they use gronk as long
as brady stays healthy that this team is
going to be a factor in 2020 and has the
chance to be one of the better teams if
not the best team in the nfc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports